to the co-parents here though
how is co-parenting is it an easy
process or a hard process
oh
um i would say
it starts off
as a hard process and you do have to
sometimes go back and forth back and
forth and then you finally get to that
to that point might be taking months
years
um to get to that point of just
understanding and realizing what the
main
you know issue is and what the
responsibility is and what you need to
do
um
speaking personally i think with my
situation um
i was with my son's dad for
six years
and it didn't work out you know and um
and obviously because i've ended the
relationship he wasn't very
happy and he still was trying
but then because i didn't want to
he didn't want to take
because we weren't together he didn't
want to do his part of being of being a
dad so
when it's like that it's definitely
challenging and um
yeah you just have to kind of
stick at it you give them the the
conditions of look this is how it's
gonna be are you able to do that if not
i'm gonna continue doing what i'm doing
until you realize
the situation so i do agree that
some people have a nice flow process of
it but some people they it depends on
how that relationship was and how you
broke how you broken up and
and if you know you can be civilized
about it when you say you gave him like
this is what's going to go on yeah
um as a father myself yeah and i don't
know if the fathers can testify to it a
lot of the time
women create hoops for fathers to jump
through
and if those fathers do not jump through
those hoops the way the woman wants the
father to jump through them then they
make it difficult
for the father to see the child
yes some people do but for myself
because it was i was like look sort
yourself out get yourself your place you
got the time i'm not going to rush you
so get yourself a job sort yourself out
and you know um
and yeah when you can
find a proper place to stay and you can
have him then you
you're welcome to i wasn't very
pushy i wasn't asking for money i was
just getting on with it because at the
end of the day i had that's how it is i
think it depends on your circumstances
and what your and what yeah and who who
broke up with who as well can i ask you
something no i mean
so you said you broke up with him yeah
yeah
how long after the kid was born did you
break up with him
um i'll say about
about five five years yeah five years
after
so
when when what was the marriage like
ever yeah i was i was engaged and
everything um and then i got and then i
fell pregnant so i was engaged and then
i got pregnant two months after
and did you consult any of your like
male
like family as to if you should
go in that direction
you know what um
not really i think how how it was
was um
yeah it wasn't something to discuss with
the family i wasn't really
you know i'm not really
close in that sense
you say that but that's
well in hindsight now you could be why
you should have went to the family if
you get what i mean
the reasons why we broke up was just our
own relationship he was also he was a
good dad we broke up you broke up with
him yes because of because there was you
know layers of things that were going on
and i'm not gonna he was willing to
sacrifice your child growing up in a
relationship with two parents as
supposed to your happiness
not really because um due to personal
reasons i've had to that was a decision
i had to make
and i do feel like um
he's
been he's he's how he was as a dad was
not questionable i knew he was good with
his son and everything but it was an
ongoing situation that had to
had to be best for the home as well i
had to look at
every angle you can't just be like you
know stay in a situation that may not be
healthy for for for the child you see
now we're getting you know i mean you've
got to be you're talking about like um
assault
what do you mean
domestic abuse oh no no no i'm not
talking about domestic abuse but i'm
just saying that um
when you both are not on the same page
and it's not working in the household
you do have to make a decision
do you know what i mean i think it's
interesting that like we say we speak on
the show all the time about um
the divorce rates and breakup rates in
the uk is 64
of
relationships marriages specifically
women are the ones to initiate the
breakup in america is as high as eighty
percent ninety percent of your colleges
ninety percent if you're college
educated yeah so if women are the ones
breaking off these relationships um and
then making it hard for the father
it's a double-edged sword do you know
what i mean like so fathers are being
broken up with and also
they are now being um told that they
can't see their children the way they
want to see their children well i think
in the in the u.s um women win custody
cases it's either 70 or 80 percent of
the time
and it's kind of like why is that
it's because women normally kick the man
out the house if if you okay if we
establish a routine of me having the kid
before i leave the house then you can't
have full custody of the kid
so what typically men make the mistake
and do is they leave the house with the
woman and the kid and then now you're
responsible for
um paying for the child right and then
she can go to court and say that he
wasn't involved even if she was keeping
him away from the kid and um the other
thing that i learned the other day in
the u.s at least um
you're entitled to 25 for one kid of a
man's income and that's after um
that's like leftover income so it's not
even taxed
so
a lot of guys get into really bad
financial situations because they make a
certain amount of money and she gets 25
even 50 if it's more than one kid of his
income say he loses the job he still has
to pay and it could be months before he
gets it changed now he's thousands of
dollars in debt
and on top of that if she's withholding
the kid then she
he had to pay thousands of dollars in
court to go see his kid so a lot of
times breaking up the family leaves a
lot of men in like financial ruins i
know and depressed suicidal go ahead
yeah sorry i know there was someone on
the show before and i know i interviewed
him myself for for on my channel and he
had spent upwards of 25k
just trying to see his child in the
family court system because he was
dealing with a mother who um you know
was trying to alienate him from his
child and i think a lot of the time when
it comes to fathers and mothers one
thing that's not spoken about the
deadbeat dad narrative is spoken about a
lot we've heard it for like decades but
what we don't hear about is like
deadbeat mothers mothers that are
alienating their children from their
actual fathers
do you know what i mean and i think i
think that needs to be spoken about a
lot because i think when it comes to
when it comes to mothers like i said
we're jumping through the hoops if you
don't do what they say
then you're a deadbeat dad and they'll
go around spreading around around the
whole town to your family friends that
you're a deadbeat dad why but just
because you didn't want to jump through
the hoops that she set but that's okay
like so there's
okay
you see some women like
they would say that about
any love their baby father if they're
not with them typically if they say it's
their friends or whatever
but if you are like
you like the guy
and you had the baby without him even
wanting the baby
so now we're talking about fathers that
want to be in the life we're not even
the kids is not even here yet i did not
want to have a kid with you
and you had the kid anyway
and now i'm forced to look after the kid
and you don't understand as a woman how
it feels because you've had the kid
inside of your belly for so long so
you're so attached so you don't
understand like why doesn't he
why isn't he like doesn't he love the
kid it's like men carry so much visceral
from women that actually like
trapped them
and it might not necessarily that i
don't
like
necessarily want to see the kid but
every time i see your face
it reminds me of
what you did do you get i'm trying to
say it's like
the kid is more of a like um
like the kid ends up getting hurt but
it's more of a extra as opposed to the
relationship so that's why when i said
to her like did you leave the
relationship it's like why would you
have a kid with me if you're going to
leave me bro
but people don't intend people don't
plan those kind of things
situations happen why have the kid then
you know and when we get married
you know even if you get married things
do happen yeah but if you get married
then it's like you're not making a kid
out of wedlock so if i'm if i go if
you've got a ring on you and i've got a
ring on me you have more responsibility
as a woman to be more to take on crap or
jimmy because what you've got to
understand yeah is that
sometimes
when men say stuff like that they're
saying well yeah you can't you can't
just get up and go because you're
married but you shouldn't be used as
that we shouldn't be looking at that
angle we shouldn't be using it for that
do you see what i mean you chose the man
so yeah and obviously again so it's not
like you're in jail you you chose the
man and we're still entitled to to if
things aren't working entitled to leave
the situation i think the question is
that